so you know how last time I cooked for
Cody yes and then you came on our show
and you're like you didn't cook for me
you cook me [__] yeah I just flipped you
off yeah I felt really bad actually okay
for seven months I've been sitting in my
head I've been going crazy jeez uh so I
decided you're a [__]
I'm sorry I'm sorry go ahead that's six
a.m I I woke up six in the morning I
woke up early I ran to my local Trader
Joe's grabbed all the stuff
yeah what the hell are you doing God
damn yeah I do smell that
nice and flavorful you know and I know
you love your flavor how how spicy are
these on a level it's not that spicy
okay yeah you can handle it because you
know I got gerd right right again
um gastro
[Music]
that was bad I hear some pita bread
you know I'm warm enough I'm warming up
um
also I made I made some for you guys if
anyone wants oh gastro a facial reflux
[__] disease
um
bird whenever you whenever you're ready
go ahead try
take a nice juicy bite
I am here in
in Malacca Thailand and I'm here with uh
actual uh uh uh uh an expat to Thailand
Wally yes yes uh
[Music]
has made uh
lamb testicles
this is lamb chops okay yeah uh walid's
lamb
um
sorry sorry sorry sorry
go ahead I was just so hot yeah
shouldn't be that hot yeah
it's a little hot you know
what's that over there
what do you think
oh it's you like it
oh good okay
it's juicy all right flavorful nice
that little kick up top is a nice little
wake up there you go
and I can't wait to see how this comes
out of my ass once you finish the whole
thing yeah don't be shy
yeah you're supposed to eat the whole
thing
go ahead all right yeah I'm getting two
you're gonna have one uh no I'm gonna
I'm gonna wait actually it's too early
to lamp are you kidding me it's like
it's like 9am
shoot yourself [__]
cash you own one are you allowed to have
one
yeah yeah I don't know I don't know the
rules
good
no this is actually delicious okay I'm
glad good morning yeah good morning yeah
just go ahead finish it whenever you can
bro
so since you're no longer a market you
can start your food truck or what
uh yeah I'm actually I'm working on it
yeah dude I've been I've been laid off
for like four months now and honestly it
feels it feels really good
feels real real good getting laid off is
that
that first day
but all the times have been laid off
it's a real struggle to pretend I'm sad
even that first day yeah yeah or my body
wants to be depressed but my mind is
just [__] dudes
dude I literally walked out of that
building smiling so happy it was so
[__] up during my meeting they're
telling me like you know the dude Mike
he's like crying he's like sad you know
what I mean he's like you know you're my
it's very personal for me you're one of
my day ones blah blah I I don't know if
it was like a nervous take or whatever I
just started laughing
I just sort of busted out
damn he's like
you guys mean a lot you're like
sir dying laughing they're like
They're laughing a bit it's really cool
and then I'm seeing all these other
people come out like tears in their eyes
and yeah it was it was it was a very
interesting moment but I'm very happy to
be out of there you think you made that
scary for him well like everyone else is
crying yours in the bad guy
[Laughter]
crazy full-on Joker moments and he's
like um
[Music]
I heard there's this one guy who walked
over to like the guy who's supposed to
essentially make more money and I
remember he had tears in his eyes
it was the funniest moment like he had
like full-on tears in his eyes he walks
over to the guy and he goes the [__] man
make more money
you just got laid off go home
it's so funny yeah it was a good time it
was a good day it was a good day [__]
bro
[__] up
we shouldn't be leaving right now that's
how you know you're [__] up
here why did you even show up to work
that day everyone's gonna be pointing
fingers at you bro
um but nothing but love for them you
know yeah shout out Market we hope they
bounce back are you done with that piece
specifically all right what's considered
done in Lamb Chop world you don't have
to eat all the fat I was just wondering
if you're done why guys we got him we
got him yep there it is
laughs
[__]
we got his ass
yes yeah why'd you take the full Beast
little do you know
um all my recent success has enabled me
to buy a new mouth so what yeah new
teeth new tongue everything yeah I got
the rapper treatment yeah [__] yeah I
was holding to the gatekeeping or
[__] can you explain
them for the audio oh oh I'm sorry audio
losers uh uh Walid reached in my pants
he was like are you done with that Lamb
Chop I'm like yeah why and he just
reached him yeah we got him he started
jerking me off
no I basically Kenny came out in a
hazmat suit uh and took the lamb chop
and put in a DNA testing bag well then
we will then do research and test on to
really find out you won't get anything
no else it's just it's just question
mark yeah no man you've never done it
you've never done the test no
here's my thing I feel like if I do it
they're just gonna be like you don't
know yeah yeah if you need to test you
don't know what you are I mean
I'm sure there's some in there you've
never
I actually had another bit I tried oh
okay
I'll tell her okay basically what I was
gonna do
oh [__] it was so good
basically Ryan would come out and be
like yo I'll eat your dogs and upstairs
is freaking out like you need to like
this is why we have a no dog rule man
you gotta like come get your dog I'm
like all right cool is it cool if it
just hangs out here I asked you for your
permission
then Ryan brings in my dog
[Laughter]
Ryan brings in a guy uh on all fours
with a leather mask shirtless
actually it was very hard to find people
who'd be down to do that bit I can't
understand I called a few people Zach
was like you really need me to do it
he like thought about it
yeah I'll do it if you really need me to
wow
Zach I love you for considering
you're a good guy for considering he
owes me so many favors he's like I guess
like you know I do owe you
whoa what what kind of what kind of
favors have you done for him that he
feels that he's in debt to you to get
into bondage I don't know actually I
guess I just helped him a lot back in
the day you know that I just been I
collect a tab of all the favors I've
done for him and then I'll just cash in
all at once damn anyways come on out
yeah you're just looking at that that
ball gag
and you're like you remember
you know why you have to do this you
remember what I've done for you
so I wasn't in the full scene yeah yeah
put it in your mouth